darunter auf den stufen des frei
gewählten deutschen parlaments dem herz
unserer demokratie das ist nicht nur
verabscheuungswürdig sondern angesichts
der geschichte dieses ortes geradezu
unerträglich wir dulden keine
antidemokratische hetze und keine
herabwürdigung der bundesrepublik
deutschland im bundestag
rechtsextremistische pöbeleien und
gewalt bei der demonstration am
vergangenen samstag in berlin haben zu
recht viele menschen erschreckt und
empört wir werden solche ausschreitungen
nicht hinnehmen wer sich über die korona
maßnahmen ärgert oder ihre notwendigkeit
anzweifelt kann und darf dagegen
demonstrieren
mein verständnis endet aber dort wo
demonstranten sich vor den karren von
demokratie feinden und politischen
hetzern spannen lassen der auf den
straßen den schulterschluss mit
rechtsextremisten sucht aber auch wer
nur gleichgültig neben neonazis fremden
feinden und antisemiten herläuft
wer sich nicht eindeutig und aktiv
abgrenzt macht sich mit ihnen gemeinden
die gewaltausschreitungen am samstag
haben wieder einmal deutlich gezeigt der
rechtsextremismus hat tiefgreifende
wurzeln in unserer gesellschaft
er ist eine ernste gefahr ihn wirksam zu
bekämpfen
seine umtriebe in den netzen frühzeitig
aufzudecken
das ist eine wichtige und andauernde
aufgabe die sicherheitsbehörden polizei
wie verfassungsschutz müssen für diese
fundamental wichtige arbeit darum die
notwendige unterstützung erhalten und
gut ausgestattet sein
allerdings meine damen und herren die
verteidigung der freiheitlichen
demokratie
ob liegt nicht allein der polizei sie
ist aufgabe und pflicht der gesamten
gesellschaft und eines jeden einzelnen
aktiv entschieden und mutig müssen wir
gemeinsam den feinden unserer demokratie
die stirn bieten wer die verstörenden
bilder von samstag gesehen hat der
musste noch schlimmeres befürchten dass
die gewalt nicht hingenommen wurde haben
wir ihnen zu verdanken der polizei
berlins der polizei anderer länder und
des bundes den vielen tausend
polizeibeamtinnen und beamten die am
samstag unter hohem persönlichen risiko
mit großer professionalität recht und
gesetz verteidigt haben unsere
demokratie lebt und kann sich ihrer
feinde erwehren sie die polizistinnen
und polizisten haben dafür gesorgt dass
zehntausende menschen der grundrechte
auf meinungs- und versammlungsfreiheit
ausüben konnten wirksam und beherzt aber
ebenso maßvoll und angemessen haben sie
gezeigt dass unser rechtsstaat
funktioniert als aber die auflagen
willentlich und wissentlich missachtet
wurden und demonstranten zur gewalt
aufriefen haben sie und der äußerst
schwierigen bedingungen die
demonstration aufgelöst und das recht
durchgesetzt
für ihren einsatz ihr vorbildliches
verhalten gewährt ihnen den
polizistinnen polizisten großer dank
respekt und anerkennung
vielen dank
auch ihnen fürs kommen danke
so jetzt können wir wieder daneben
angehen
wir gehen da zurück